luz Raquel Padilla murió quemada
desconocidos incendiaron su cuerpo sus
familiares y activistas demandan
Justicia con pancartas y gritos frente a
una comisaría en México una compañera
muy activa bella mucho por todo nuestros
niños El grito no es solo por los Raquel
sino por las cientos de mujeres que han
sido asesinadas en el territorio
mexicano critican la inacción del
gobierno por su parte el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador atribuyó el
asesinato de luz Raquel a la política
neoliberal la basta de denegar lo que
vivimos las que cuidamos basta denegar y
de hacernos invisibles porque nosotras
como cuidadoras dejamos todo todo por
cuidar a nuestros hijos y el gobierno
pues no nos apoyan esta semana se
reabrió el debate de la violencia de
género en dicho país debido a los nuevos
hallazgos sobre la muerte de banescobar
una joven de 18 años que desapareció el
pasado 9 de abril la fiscalía determinó
que las causas de su fallecimiento no
fueron accidentales
Y es que casos como el de luz y debanhi
muestran con nombres propios el problema
a gran escala al que se enfrenta México
según cifras oficiales 10 mujeres son
asesinadas a diario en el país Solo este
año se han reportado 493 casos de
muertes violentas de mujeres y según la
Secretaría de Seguridad y protección
ciudadana solo en junio se han
presentado 89 feminicidios el mes más
letal de este año aunque las cifras han
bajado un 8% interanual frente a 2021
múltiples ongs y activistas demandan
mayores acciones por parte del gobierno
amnistía internacional lo tildó
indolente este mes